hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from round 10 of the 1980
New York tournament a couple monk once
again faces Canadian master Jon Stewart
Morrison this is the second time he
faces him in this tournament he already
defeated him in the first part of the
tournament but now Morrison has an
opportunity to grab a revenge with the
white pieces and it's one of the more
exciting games in the reuleaux place you
will see well you've seen in a while I
imagine as I found it to be very
exciting especially since its opposite
side castles and it's just a really
complicated game couple on conventions
this game in his book and he often says
that it's really uh you know positions
that arise in this game are very
complicated and he did not want to go
into details in his book because it
would simply take too much space which
you will see and you will also have a
very nice opportunity to find some of
some moves to find uh even a move that
couple Blanca missed and it's just gonna
be a very nice well we can improve our I
hope so without further ado let's check
out the game Morrison has the white
pieces and he opens with E for as we
already mentioned it will be the rule
opus with Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 and
now Capablanca goes for d6 this is the
old Chinese defense but as usual
capablanca doesn't really put all that
much thought into what opening he will
play he's just gonna play some moves and
then he will play good chess with Knight
to c3 Bishop to d7 the for now he
captures on d4 Knight captures and here
we have g6 the standard idea in the old
Stein it's aligned with Knight back to
f3 as this Knight would well become an
object of attack after this Bishop is
fianchettoed here so Knight to f3 Bishop
to g7 and now Bishop to g5 by Morrison
Knight to f6 blocking the attack and
also preparing the castle we have Queen
to d2 Morrison signal a signifies that
he will go for a queenside castle
we have h6 Bishop to h4 and now
Capablanca castles and here just
queenside castle by white so as you can
see all pieces stone the board only one
point has been exchanged and it's an
opposite side castle so you will most
likely we will see an attack first rook
to e8 by Capablanca just a nice
developing move without wasting time now
the e4 pawn is under attack not
immediately as
there's the spin but after you kick away
the bishop with g5 then of course you
will be threatening to win the pawn so
we have Group H to e1 and I centralizing
move by Morris and also defending the
pawn and now capablanca goes g5 he
doesn't mind advancing the pawns in
front of his King a bit as he's gonna go
Knight to h5 now he has a control of
this tension he can grab the bishop
whenever he wants and also his dark
square bishop which is well the dragon
now comes alive and it's just a very
active piece so compensation enough for
the advancement of the pawns in front of
the King with Knight the d5 white also
wants to have a nice well a nice night
in the center of the board and also he
wants to play C 3 which will well just
take take a take away a few squares from
the c6 Knight and also reduce the power
of capablanca Bishop on g7 we have a6
pushing the Bushra back Bishop to d3 and
now Bishop to e6 and here just c3 as
planned
just taking away some of the squares
from the Black Knight and also now the
bishop doesn't have such a such a clear
target we have F 5 by capablanca taking
this opportunity for this very nice move
of course you cannot capture as your
knight on d5 would be hanging and on the
other hand you're threatening f4 which
would trap blacks and bishops so white
has to react white goes h4 creates a
room on h2 4 for his Bishop but also
prepares a very nice attack here we have
f4 by capablanca and now comes H
captures on g5 and here Morrison says
you you defeated me in the first part of
the tournament where you had the black
or the white pieces now I'm gonna go all
out and you know you just take my bishop
and I'm just gonna attack you and win a
very nice game and indeed if a couple
Monica captures the bishop white will
get a very nice attack after rook h1
threatening to capture the night rush of
G for just defending and now G captures
and h6 so it's a it's a piece for 2
points after Bishop to f6 it's a it's a
game white of course
pretty much everyone would prefer white
here it's just a very nice attack you
didn't even sacrifice all that much you
did gain it get two points for for your
piece and
well it's just an unpleasant position
for black so a couple blanca says no
thank you I'm not interested in your
bishop he just plays H captures on g5
we've looked to H one nonetheless
pressuring night here and taking control
of the open H file with Bishop back to
f7 by capablanca now defending the
knight and here King to be one always a
useful move you know just getting the
the the King out of this well you know
you don't want the Queen and King
occupying the same diagonal especially
since a black still has his dark square
bishop so King to be one and now again
offering capablanca to capture the
bishop and if f captures now it's even
more dangerous just Knight character son
g5 and it's it's a very difficult
position to defend for black you're
threatening to remove the defender of
the night on H five after removed the
night you can go F capture some g3 and
you just have so many lines for
attacking it's well it's it's not not no
one would play this position will black
in there in the right mind you know just
for for grabbing a piece since the
blacks didn't even finish development so
after a king to be one with Knight to e5
by capablanca saying okay I'm just gonna
trade down one more piece and then I'm
gonna take your Bishop with Knight
captures on e5 rook captures on e5 and
here finally Morrison steps back we have
Bishop - H - now that one more piece has
been exchanged he no longer offers the
piece with Knight to f6 capablanca now
takes this opportunity as the H file is
closed at the trade off yet another
piece and here we have g3 Morrison wants
to open lines in front of the in front
of Cobo Blancas King we have Knight
captures on e4
Bishop captures on e4 rook captures on
e4 and now G captures on f4 and here
Capablanca plays c6 and this is one of
the positions that Capablanca mentions
in his book he says that black is
already practically winning here it's
just a matter of time and here white has
to make a move so in the game the game
continued Knights - III as the knight is
attacked you have to go back then couple
bunker goes Queen to a5
well starts an attack and it just
becomes very difficult to defend for
white but there is a move that
Capablanca overlooked in his analysis
and it is a very nice move seems like
moving the night is a bit bit too
automatic a move for white so maybe
maybe there's a better move so feel free
to pause the video it is a nice Friday
you know maybe you're interested in
finding this move that couple noncom
missed in the game and also in his
analysis start to say if he missed it in
India analysis maybe he just didn't want
to mention it in the book maybe he I
mean he didn't want to calculate it for
the book who knows who knows what's the
idea but you have you know a lot more
time you can pause the video and then
you can find the right move so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the the idea that white missed in this
game I'll give you a couple of seconds
as usual for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations you have just
found a move capablanca missed so that
in itself is just you know huge praise
and you should be very happy with
yourself and full of you just won't
enjoy it so the idea is f3 a move before
deciding what to do with tonight forcing
black to deal with the rook on e4 and
now you will see that it's not all that
easy because well let's say black moves
the rook somewhere along the e-file
let's say he goes back look to e8 now
you just got nice to be four and what
happens next
white black has to play a move and white
has a lot of threats white has an open H
file white has a queen here it's not all
that easy to push any points here if you
start pushing pause Knight gets the d5
square and well you don't want to give
up any of your bishops here then your
Kings position will be loose I mean it
will be hard to defend if you bring the
rook over to g1 you will have a lot of
attacking life so let's say something
like a 5 you can go night the c2 and now
if a 4 you can go rook D to G 1 and it's
just a very pleasant position for white
much different than what happened in the
game and on the other hand if after f3
you decide not to go back along the
e-file let's say we'll look to a for now
it is a a nice pressure remove your
already pressuring the a to pawn the
bishop is also attacking that Queen can
come to a5 also with further pressure
towards the a to pawn then you can go
Queen to c2 just attack that rook and
let's say b5 you defend it now comes b3
again you
tag the rook and now if rook to a5 then
well black will be in a lot of trouble
just Knight to be for getting the knight
out of the way and now comes well you
have to play something with black let's
the Queen to f6 pressuring the the c3
pawn but now just f5 and here black has
to play something let's say Bishop to h5
attacking in the pawn here now you go
Bishop to e5 and take advantage of well
finally this open H file you have for
your Queen captures rook captures and
now after Queen captures on c3 you can
just trade for example Queen captures
Bishop captures Knight captures and c6
attacking the rook rook to a3 and now
after rook captures and b6 for example
white will have a winning endgame this
rook isn't really going anywhere white
is up material and it's just a much
better position for white so in this
position after c6 f3 really a dangerous
move and it would really really give a
lot to John Stuart Morrison but he went
back with the night and now Capablanca
just you know jumped in with the Queen
we have Queen to a5 already threatening
and now it's too late for such things
even if every now black doesn't even
have to capture you can go low k4 and
now if even if white rice the block is
you just give up the rook now capture
send Bishop captures on c3 it's a game
over Queen c2 Queen captures there's
really not all that much you can do
against Queen a1 checkmate
you could move the Queen but then you
get rook to e8 again with the threat of
rook captures and Bishop to g6 check I
mean there's just too many too many
threats here so after Queen to a5 black
decided okay I'm just gonna block the C
file and offer a trade of Queens here
and kappa blanka says okay sure Queen
captures with rook captures and now G
captures on f4 and now the problem is
after the Knight moves a Knight to g4
with Bishop to g6 already threatening a
lot of nasty discoveries I mean there's
just not all that much you can do rook
e1 will be checkmate if this is allowed
and now after trying to attack
Capablanca for an entire game now we're
just in an endgame where you're down
material and where you have a much worse
position so you have to react to this
with King to a-1 not
the nasty discovery we have rook 88
again going for mate rook e1 would
result in checkmate so we have a three
making some room for morrison's King but
now rook e1 check just exchanging a pair
of rooks captures captures with check
King 2 a 2 and not Bishop to f7 again
threatening to capture here with check
we have King Tubby 3 blocking and now d5
capablanca is just merciless and doesn't
allow even a second for white you know
to recover his forces with Bishop
captures on f4 you don't want this
bishop stranded on h2 for the rest of
the game but now just D captures on c4
with King to b4 and now again not
leaving white any time to recover c3
just a just a you know beautiful move
threatens to win the rook if white moves
the rook or captures the pawn then rook
to e4 Czech wins the bishop there's
there's no way to defend both threats so
we have B captures on c3 better to give
up at least a bishop then a look but
rook to e4 check comes
we have c4 you can go back the bishop
covers the be three square so c4 now
first rook captures on c4 with check
with King to a5
now comes the rook captures an F for
threatening to win the night here okay
rook to d8 check we have king to h7 and
now comes work to b7 hoping at least to
trade something here but Capablanca goes
brush up to e6 and it was in this
position that jon stewart morrison
resigned in the game so morrison versus
Capablanca in this tournament Capablanca
wins in both games and he won every game
so far in this tournament for well
except one against the first time
against Roy Turnbull black that was
drawn but just crushing this tournament
and you know he's really coming into
form to prepare for his match against a
world champion Emanuel Alaska there's of
course nothing to do here you have to
give up the exchange where you're just
gonna lose a piece after captures
captures and you move the knight a
couple of one guys up a whole rook it's
of course pointless to even even
continue talking about this I would say
over there after Bishop d6 Morrison
resigned the game and yet another
wonderful victory for josé raúl
capablanca in this tournament so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Kenneth McKay of
Scotland
tarah Scarpia kaberi makhmur doc human
siren and Hussein Ishmael off for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video Siri thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
couple Blanca saga but also the feeder
Grand Prix started so we're gonna cover
a few games from that as well also I
guess sometimes tomorrow morning I will
start covering that so you know don't
worry Google show some of the games from
from that tournament as well as it is a
part of the feeder World Chess
Championship cycle so thank you I will
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your weekend